[Music]
are you ready for a new kind of Disney
movie full of strong female characters
no forced romantic subplots and a
celebration of Polynesian culture then
you'll love lilo and Stitch did not see
that coming oh and probably awesome
wanna meet Moana a strong determined
young woman who won't stop until she
gets the job done I board my boat sail
across the sea and restore the heart of
TBT who after 90 minutes of adventure
becomes a strong determined young woman
who won't stop until she gets the job
done I am warning you will board my boat
they'll cost a fee and restore the heart
of defeat see she's indestructible she's
fearless and she's got water powers just
as confusing and vague as Elsa's ice
magic and frozen so wait does she even
have any water powers at all or does it
only protect whoever has the glowy thing
and if the ocean has her back why does
it keep trying to drown her follow along
with Mona's quest to save her homeland
by following a super obvious sign Maui
lies bad in a journey that pokes fun at
all of Disney's usual tropes if you
weren't dressed and you have an animal
sidekick you're a princess if you start
singing I'm gonna throw up while at the
same time being 100% guilty of them from
her cute animal sidekicks to a grandma
fossa to her genie Maui and all powerful
charismatic brawling tattooed demigod so
pretty much the rock enjoy the highest
honor a culture can receive these days
having your traditions commodified by
the Disney Corporation and watch as the
Polynesian people who traveled between
islands thousands of miles apart
thousands of years ago are represented
by paranoid coconut lovers who would
rather starve to death and self as a
three-foot break we were voyages we get
voyage again haole forever I guess so
enjoy a film with a soundtrack people
can't stop gushing about because
the guy from Hamilton is involved and
not even the ocean gushes as hard as
Hamilton fans featuring songs like the
they're really into coconut song when
you turn 13 we're making the rock sing
song you can smell what I'm cooking I'll
save your franchise make money no
problem you all recognize my voice by
five but at one respects a kind of
flawed
do anything except sing auto-tune
couldn't get me on track president
someday still I can't sing but who else
pulls off a fanny pack then let it go
they saw
[Music]
he makes more money than you should
like a friend let it go
and the beautiful song in a foreign
language that could be saying anything
song
Oh
and my way
Hey
I hope you like that one because it
turns out it's really freaking hard to
find a Tokyo Island translator starring
Nemo choking the chicken
David glowy hi guys and wow Choi
Polamalu really let himself go
Pacific swim okay so wait a second
Rapunzel has demon hair else has ice
powers and Moana is a waterbender are we
building up to disney's princess
avengers hey screen junkies who doesn't
need more of the rock in their life
click the box on the left to see Dwayne
the rock Johnson play all of your
favorite Disney characters as only he
can and if you want to learn more about
Moana click the Box on the right to
watch our interview with Jared Busch
screenwriter of Moana and the
oscar-winning Zootopia bargain I've come
to Dormammu potatoes will end humanity
as the prophecy foretold and the Oscar
goes to Suicide Squad my favorite movie
last year was lala land
I mean moonlight I gave Warren Beatty
the wrong envelope